cinco días de intensas manifestaciones
le ganaron el pulso al conservador
iván duque el presidente colombiano echó
para atrás una polémica reforma
tributaria impulsada por su ejecutivo
les solicitó al congreso de la república
el retiro del proyecto radicado por el
ministerio de hacienda y tramitar de
manera urgente un nuevo proyecto fruto
de los consensos y así evitar
incertidumbre financiera la llamada ley
de solidaridad sostenible provocó el
rechazo de miles de ciudadanos esta
proponía reunir unos seis mil millones
de dólares con impuestos que habrían
recaído principalmente en las clases
media y baja sin comprometer en gran
medida a las empresas los grandes
capitales y el sector financiero
se produjeron múltiples altercados y
saqueos aunque las protestas fueron
principalmente pacíficas organizaciones
defensoras de los derechos humanos
denuncian una violenta represión de la
policía y los escuadrones antidisturbios
mi enorme preocupación por la situación
en colombia reitero mi llamado urgente a
que la protesta sea pacífica y las
fuerzas de seguridad respeten los
derechos humanos con la retirada el
presidente aseguró que se eliminarán los
impuestos que perjudican a la canasta
familiar y propuso aumentar los aportes
de los grandes capitales pero el llamado
a la huelga continúa en un país en el
que en 2020 más de 35 millones de
personas entraron a situación de pobreza
según el departamento nacional de
estadísticas las negociaciones de una
reforma tributaria son para muchos una
cuestión de vida o muerte